As we said earlier, RVM has to be
efficient, otherwise, no one will use it. The run
time does not actually write the persistent data,
that is specified through the set range call. Directly
to the external data segments. Instead, it writes
the changes that it made to the block of
addresses, specified by the set range call as a
redo log in a log segment that was named
in the initialized call, and we know that
the log segment is the trick that we mentioned
earlier also to avoid. Random writes to the
disc. The log segment is an in memory data
structure of the RVM run time and once
a transaction commits at that point, the log segment,
that contains the changes that have been made
to the in memory version of persistence data structures.
Will be committed to the disc. Or, in other words, RVM writes the
changes that the developer's making to persistent data structures
in between begin and end transaction as redo logs end
the log segment. And the redo log that has been written into the log segment is
committed to the disc at the point of
end transaction. On the other hand, if the transaction
aborts, then you don't have to commit those
reader logs to the disc.Now remember that the changes
that we make to the perisistent data structrues
in memory versions of those persistent data strutures Have
to be eventually committed to the external data
segments. Now that part is done lazily by the
RBM system. It basically applies the redo logs that
have been committed to the disk to the external
data segments at opportune moments, and once it has
applied those Redo logs from the log segment in
to the external data segments. The redo logs can
be thrown away. And this part is what is called
truncation. So there are two parts to managing the
log. One is at the point of commitment, the log
has to be forced to the disc, because you
want to persist it. And second, once it is comitted
to the disc. You have to eventually apply it
to the external data segments and at that point, you
can truncate the logs. So the log is going to
be applied to the external data segments and once those
external data segments have been modified, then you can
throw away those reader logs. So flushing the log segment
to the disk, as well as Truncating the log segment
once they have been applied to the external data segments
that they represent are all done automatically
by LRVM. So the application developer doesn't have
to do anything other than initialize his
virtual memory The log segment he wants to
use and write the code that contains
these critical sections bound by begin transaction and
end transaction and abort transaction. But RVM
also provides flush and truncate as primitives for
flexibility in writing the application. Or in other words, the application Can
if it chooses explicitly manage the
persistence and application of the [UNKNOWN] logs
to the data segments. Shortly we
will mention some optimization specified through the
commit mode to the RVM [UNKNOWN]
by the application programmer. To enhance performance.
One of those optimization features allows the
RVM to defer flushing to the disc at
the point of commit. So one of those
optimization features in the commit mode is to
tell the RVM. Do not flush the changes to the log segment commit point yet.
I'll take care of it explicitly by flushing.
So these additional primitives are for the developers
if she so chooses to explicitly controlling flushing
of the logs to the disk and also
manage the truncation of the logs by explicitly
applying it when she wants it To the external
data segments to conserve space, because if you
think about it all these log segments are
occupying space on the disc. At the midpoint
you're flushing the redo records in the log segments
to the disc. And so you're filling up the disc with a lot of redo records
in addition to the external data segments. The
truncation is a way by which. The subsystem
designer, can explicitly say, go ahead and apply
these edulogs to the extremity segments and truncate
the log. So as i said, these calls
are there, purely for flexibility, if their designer so
chooses to use these primitives for explicitly
Controlling and reducing the log space. And
these additional perimeters are available in RVM
as a way by which the developer can
administer the design of a subsystem and
performance tune his subsystem for optimality. The
main thing to take away is that the RVM design is simple, with a small
set of primitives. Easy to grok for a developer and use in the design of
a subsystem. Also, we've been using the word
transaction. But the semantics of the transaction as
used in RVM. Is much more restricted compared
to the traditional use of the word transaction
in the database literature. In particular, the transaction
as proposed and used in the RVM library,
is intended for recovery management. It does not need all the properties
that are usually associated With traditional
transaction, so called acid properties, namely atomicity,
consistency, isolation, and durability. For example,
a transaction as defined in RVM,
does not allow for nested transactions.
It has no support for concurrency control.
But all of these are things that you
normally associate as transaction for the key design objective.
In RVM is to make it simple, and performant,
and easy to use. And if there is need
for concurrency control, it is something that the
developer has to implement at a higher level in
their system software. So in this sense. It is
useful to remember what I said earlier that the
code that exists between begin transaction and end
transaction is like a critical section in the
application code. And all that the developer is
trying to signal through the critical section to
the RVM library is that it is making changes to a portion Of an address range
and that potion of the address range, it
needs to be persistent if in fact that critical
section bound by this n transaction commits. On the other
hand, if that critical section aborts then those changes should be
thrown away. That's the intent of a set of primitives
provided by RVM and that's the intent of this transaction semantic.